Yo what's up. Welcome to my apartment again.
So today we don't have Matt show cause matcha is feeling kind of sick.
So we got this replacement guy, but I know he's, you're hungry.
I don't think I have much because my roommates are not here, but Oh my God,
what the great courses, plus I did not expect you that. Oh,
so today we are sponsored by the great courses plus,
which is a video learning service.
We are going to talk about this at the end of the video,
but for now let's talk about something more important in my room.
[Inaudible].
All right.
So the thing I want to talk about today is about self-improvement and
also personal development.
And the reason why I want to talk about this is because it's something that
affected me at work and it's something that I overcame,
or at least I'm trying to overcome. So in my opinion,
the number one blocker for most people to reach their maximum potential
is their ego. And that was especially true for me.
And I recognized it in college and also at work,
it's still something that I'm working on. For example, in college,
my number one blocker was that I was too scared of taking advanced
courses or too scared of partaking in competitions because I was
scared of failing because I had a sensitive ego.
And then at work, I did not ask for feedback that much.
And the reason why is because negative criticism hurt me.
I think the reason why I have this ego problem is
because I never really failed in life when I was a kid. Um,
I think this is also true for most people with this fixed mindset.
So a lot of these people I've recognized them through classmates and coworkers,
that when they were small in elementary school, high school,
they were always the smartest, getting good grades came easy to them.
So it was never a problem for them.
So failing was almost a foreign concept to them, but then once they hit it,
once they had their first failure, it hurts. It hurts a lot.
And what happens when things hurt a lot, you don't do anymore.
You shelter yourself. And then this failure usually bruises their ego.
And because their ego is bruise, they don't want to do it anymore.
They rather not take any risks and do things that are a lot easier so that they
can feel comfortable to prevent another failure.
And then feedback in some ways is a form of failure,
or at least it evokes the same emotion because essentially what you're doing is
you're letting yourself be vulnerable because you're letting people say negative
criticism about your work or about you in general. And that is a scary thing.
And I still, I'm still, I'm S I'm still struggling with that,
but I'm working on it.
And the feedback has been great because the work that I've done before getting
feedback and the work that I've done after my feedback is day and night.
It's so clear that after getting feedback, my work is so much better.
I communicate better. My analysis is more rigorous.
Everything is just a lot better because I asked for feedback and he,
so I hope that was useful. Uh, in conclusion,
the only thing I want you to remember is to ask for feedback and be
ego-less all right. So like I said before,
this video is sponsored by the great courses plus,
and because this video is sponsored,
I can afford to buy Metro and the iPhone 10. So he doesn't know it yet.
And unfortunately he's a little bit too sick to come over.
So what I did was I hit the iPhone 10 inside the box of a stabilizer,
which he owns and it's at his house right now. So yeah,
I just wanted to buy him an iPhone 10 because, uh,
I just want to thank him for all the work that he has done for me.
And he definitely deserves it. So yeah, this let's, uh, let's call him up. Yo,
Matt. Hello? Yo, what's up, man?
How you doing? I hope you're feeling better. Yeah.
Cool. You, uh, I want you to do something for me.
Uh, you know, that crane that you have go,
can you go to it first?
Yeah, yeah. Uh, next to it.
All right. Open it and dig deep inside.
Oh. There's an iPhone 10 in here.
It's yours.
Boy. It's yours serious.
Yo, you had like a crappy iPhone six. I think.
I think I want you to have this iPhone 10.
Oh my gosh. You like it? Yeah.
Yeah. Thanks man.
You'll no problem, man. But, uh, yeah.
Can you redo that with more enthusiasm for the video?
No, but yeah. I'm glad you like it. I just wanted to say, yeah,
thank you for all the hard work that you've done for me. And uh, yeah.
I just really appreciate you and I hope this gift.
It will be useful for you.
Thank you.
Yeah, no problem, man. Have fun.
Yeah. But.
Thank you so much. The great courses, plus for sponsoring this video,
the great courses plus is a subscription on demand,
video learning service with top-notch lectures and courses from top professors
from the Ivy league and other great universities globally and experts from
places like national geographic,
the Smithsonian and the culinary Institute of it has unlimited access to a
huge library of over 10,000 video lectures about anything that interests you,
data science, math, history, literature, or even how to cook,
play chess or become a better photographer.
I actually binge watched a course called Saifai science fiction and philosophy.
The course is cool because it takes a Poplar Saifai movie and it relates to a
philosophical topic that the movie touched upon.
So I got to learn the deeper meanings of the movies, like the matrix star Wars,
and many more. I was able to hook you guys up.
So get a free trial by visiting the great courses plus.com/joma or by
clicking on the link down below, please check them out.
It really helps support my channel anyways. That's it for today?
Hope you guys have a wonderful day and I'll see you.
The livestream
[inaudible] we're going to go to [inaudible]
, which is one of the best restaurants in Palo Alto. So good. But yeah, let's check it out. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.